kommen wir zum schmutzigen geschäft der
schleuser die also die brutal
abkassieren für ein versprechen an all
diese flüchtlinge wir bringen euch nach
europa jeden tag hunderte tausende
von belarus nach polen vor allen dingen
im moment weiter nach deutschland das
ist ein brutales geschäft dass
lukaschenko und putin betreiben und
hinter den beiden diesen diktatoren
steht ein weit verzweigtes netzwerk
moskau minsk und auch istanbul das sind
die flüchtlings routen und dort sitzen
sie die verwalter der flüchtlingskrise
die organisatoren die schleuser beruf
also flüchtlings schleuser seit jahren
versucht die politik diesen verbrechern
das handwerk zu legen bei unserer
reporterin klara marie becker in
istanbul packt jetzt einer aus ein
insider dieses geschäftes
sie stehen am polnischen grenzzaun und
rufen germany germany tausende
flüchtlinge campieren seit wochen in
weller russischen wäldern und versuchen
verzweifelt über die grenze nach polen
zu kommen jeden tag werden es hunderte
mehr viele kommen aus syrien dem irak
und dem iran
die flucht führt für einige der
flüchtlinge aus dem mittleren osten über
die türkei über istanbul
betreffen und ziehe im europäischen teil
der stadt mit einem ex schleuser der uns
einiges über den organisiertem
menschenschmuggel in der türkei erzählt
er möchte unerkannt bleiben und wir
dürfen nur in seiner wohnung drehen wir
wollen von ihm wissen woher die
flüchtlinge an der polnisch
belarussischen grenze kommen und wie er
sie dorthin gebracht hat
ich sag mal so über die türkei kommen
die menschen aus syrien iran irak
afghanistan pakistan bangladesch früher
haben sie das land über griechenland
verlassen in boten in gruppen von 100
200 personen sind sie nach griechenland
oder italien gefahren
wann hat sich die route über bilder groß
etabliert ist das einfacher
wer über belarus flieht hat es sehr
leicht in der letzten zeit war das der
bequemste weg weil die polen jetzt aber
starke maßnahmen gezogen haben kommt
moment keiner durch jeden tag starten
drei linienflieger von turkish airlines
und bellaria er vom istanbul airport
nach minsk am gate treffen wir acht
junge iraker die ebenfalls nach minsk
wollen ihr ziel deutschland die
flugtickets und visa die die flüchtlinge
für die einreise nach belarus brauchen
besorgen häufig die schleuser manche
versuchen es auf eigene faust und
beantragen ein visum im bella russischen
konsulat in istanbul von unserem insider
erfahren wir dass viele schleuser in
istanbul ein reisebüro eröffnen die
griechenland- und belarus route wird von
den afghanen organisiert auch türken
sind involviert aber ich würde mal sagen
80 prozent sind aufgaben und was ist mit
den türkischen behörden tolerieren sie
die schleuse aktivitäten oder helfen sie
den schleusern sogar dabei flüchtlinge
über die grenze zu bringen wenn am ende
geld auf sie wartet rückt die türkische
polizei immer ein auge zu wenn sie
keinen eigenen vorteil davon haben dann
drücken sie kein auge zu wenn es um
ausländer geht die zum beispiel von
edirne nach griechenland ausreisen die
werden niemals von der ausreise
abgehalten die denken sich wenn er gehen
will soll er gehen die türkischen
sicherheitsbehörden halten im
zusammenhang mit ausländern niemanden
auf und obwohl die flüchtlinge wissen
dass sie eventuell wochen lang an der
grenze zwischen belarus und polen fest
sitzen ohne essen und ohne unterkunft
wollen sie trotzdem hin erzählt uns der
ex schleuser sie fliehen vor
arbeitslosigkeit in ihrem land oder weil
sie politisch verfolgt werden der
verwandtschaft in der eu hat versucht zu
seinen verwandten zu reisen wer
niemanden hat ist nicht wählerisch
hauptsache das ziel ist ein land in der
europäischen union
ja das interview mit diesem schleuser
der sich natürlich nur von hinten filmen
lassen wollte ja ein geheimes interview
das hat geführt klara marie becker
unsere reporterin und sie es uns jetzt
auch zugeschaltet aus ist dann wohl
klarer wie war es für dich diesem mann
zu begegnen wir hatte auf dich gewirkt
wissend was für ein geschäft er betreibt
aber er hat ja auch dir seine ganz
persönliche geschichte erzählt
ja genau wir haben uns mit ihm im
europäischen stadtteil von istanbul
getroffen in seiner wohnung er wollte
eben nicht dass wir draußen mit ihrem
film weil er gesagt hat jeder kennt
ihnen hier die würden dann fragen
stellen weshalb er jetzt mit einem
kamerateam unterwegs ist deswegen hat er
gesagt er möchte nur in seiner wohnung
drehen um unerkannt zu bleiben auch in
den straßen und er selber schleuste
aktuell keine flüchtigen mehr sollte er
uns das zumindest geschildert aber er
ist auch mitglied der türkischen mafia
und seine bekannten und freunde dort
sind selber noch als schleuser aktiv und
auch die mafia verdient ja an diesem
schleuser geschäfte bei jetzt bist du
rangekommen klarer an diese schleuser
mafia was ist dein eindruck jetzt im
moment dort aktuelle in istanbul wie
groß und wie gut organisiert ist diese
szene
das ist ehrlich gesagt schwierig
einzuschätzen also er wollte uns
natürlich wenig darüber erzählen wie
auch die leute untereinander in istanbul
zusammenarbeiten
man muss allerdings sagen wir waren
jetzt auch einige tage ich habe im
flughafen wir sind auch viel in istanbul
unterwegs gewesen in diesen ecken wo
eben zum beispiel auch reisebüros sind
die schleuser eröffnet haben um von dort
aus ihre aktivitäten zu organisieren und
das ist alles sehr
undercover kann man sagen also man muss
schon wirklich sehr aktiv suchen um
leute zu finden die jetzt aktuell
versuchen ja aus istanbul nach minsk zu
fliegen und die möchten dann häufig
nicht mit einem sprechen weil sie
natürlich angst haben dass sie nicht
hinkommen und dass es vorher aufgehalten
werden
wie kommen denn die flüchtlinge dann in
istanbul überhaupt in kontakt mit den
schleusern wie läuft dieser weg
der ex schleuser hat uns erzählt dass
eben häufig der weg über diese
reisebüros geht denn die sind nicht nur
ein sehr guter deckmantel für die
schleuser sondern sie sind natürlich
auch eine anlaufstelle das heißt die
flüchtlinge wissen dann heute ist er wo
sie hingehen müssen wenn sie ein name
von einem reisebüro haben als wenn sie
jetzt irgendwie sich in der straße
umschauen müssen
dort werden dann häufig nehmen die
flüchtlinge dann kontakt zu den
schleusern auf und die sind dann auch
häufig diejenigen die sich um die
flugtickets kümmern um die visa kümmern
wir waren auch vor dem russischen
konsulat in istanbul da waren zum
beispiel ungefähr 30 männer die es auf
eigene faust versucht haben ihr visum
dort zu beantragen um dann sie waren
also viele von ihnen waren aus der irak
aus dem iran aus syrien
das haben sie uns noch gesagt aber
danach wollten sie auch nicht mehr mit
uns sprechen es war aber sehr
offensichtlich dass sie dort gewartet
haben auf ein visum
du beobachtest für uns ja auch was so am
flughafen von istanbul gerade passiert
hast du den eindruck dass dort sich
derzeit viele menschen aufhalten die auf
einen weiterflug nach minsk warten
nein also wir waren sie gesagt auch
schon die letzten tage vor ort und es
ist jetzt nicht so als würden sich hier
massen von menschen vor dem flughafen
sammeln die irgendwie verzweifelt suchen
versuchen einen flug zu bekommen
das ist passiert alles sehr unscheinbar
also hinter den kulissen häufig findet
man oder wir haben jetzt am check-in
auch in den letzten tagen immer wieder
nach menschen gesucht die versuchen nach
belarus zu reisen nach wien zu reisen
und sind ja eigentlich auch fast keine
menschen betroffen am gate wiederum
schon da würde ich sagen ja sind es
immer so um die zehn menschen vielleicht
häufig eben auch aus dem irak die
nach münchen reisen und mit einigen von
ihnen habe ich auch gesprochen und sie
wollten sich bei mir melden wenn sie in
mainz angekommen sind das haben sie auch
getan sie haben nur geschrieben wir sind
gut gelandet uns geht es gut beide
chemie alles von ihnen bis jetzt noch
nicht gehört